[Music]  i'm throwing myself into the unknown  i almost guarantee you're gonna survive  all right  there's a new breed of explorers taking  me to the ends of the earth  to discover hidden worlds  that sit beyond our senses  how's that feeling scary as hell you  know exactly how it feels  once you decode the mysteries  you can find crucial information about  the world around us  ready when you are we're trying to see  the invisible wow  so i could be one of the first people to  ever see this  inside the sub at 3 000 feet and the  only thing protecting you is about six  inches of plastic we down here y'all we  down here  you gotta be kidding me  that was beautiful wow  anything dangling just you  i'm not gonna need to do that two times  no  that looks crazy  it's a different planet down there  how did i not know that this was in the  world  wow  i'm still putting this in a movie  i'm so quick  [Music]  [Music]  you